several Jewish groups have stormed the
Al-Aqsa mosque compound and occupied
East Jerusalem the incursions occurred
as Palestinian worshipers conducted
morning prayers
Israeli forces escorted seven groups of
Israeli settlers into the courtyards
earlier hundreds of Palestinian youths
were prevented from accessing the
mosque's compound for Dawn prayers well
Russell cerda joins us now from occupied
East Jerusalem and Russell this is all
happening at a time of height and
tension there can you just give us a bit
of an update on on this incursion this
morning in in Al-Aqsa
well today we have seen that there have
been 18 Jewish groups are getting into
the Alexa mosque a relaxer compound in
general and while they were getting in
it the Palestinian worshipers overnight
worshipers also were there and
conducting their prayers however today
was a little bit different normally the
tension Rises here when the Israel
occupation forces tried to remove the
Palestinian worshipers and when the
Jewish Ultra Nationals get into the
compound usually they are guarded by the
Israeli occupation forces and that
Israeli occupation forces interfere to
the Palestinian warshipers but today we
have seen that side by side they they
conducted their prayers and and worship
and Israeli occupation forces didn't
remove their Palestinian groups that's
why the situation today is relatively
calm here so far more than 1 200 Jewish
people they got into the compound but as
of now there's not that much of the
tension of course one of the reasons for
that according to people that are
familiar with this situation and the
analysts and so on they say that both
sides are restraining from escalating
the tension so we have seen that
recently the Israeli authorities are
also sending out mild messages and also
the Palestinian groups including Hamas
and Al Jihad as well in their unofficial
statements that say that if Israel
doesn't escalate they are also not
willing to escalate so it is mostly up
to how the Israeli occupation forces are
going to behave the Palestinian
worshipers but as of now the situation
is relatively cool okay we're just on
those forces the Israeli Police
Commissioner has commented on the videos
of Palestinians being beaten by Israeli
forces last week what did he have to say
well in the it's a real statement so one
of the top Israeli police officers
saying that the images that were sent
out particularly on the day of Wednesday
and Thursday where when Israeli
occupation forces stormed Al-Aqsa mosque
and forcefully removed the Palestinian
overnight worshipers and arrested around
20 of them and so and injured around 20
of them and arrested nearly 400
Palestinians so that image is using
excessive force in the Holy compound of
of Al-Aqsa mosque that images he says
that has created a terrible impact
however that doesn't mean that he didn't
defend the police he said that police
had to do that however they could be a
little bit more measured so the Israeli
officials here are seeing that starting
from Wednesday on they are going to ban
the Jewish group Ultra nationalist
Jewish group getting into the compound
this is a practice of the recent years
to avoid the conflict and also as
Muslims are still observing Ramadan in
the the last 10 days of Ramadan which is
starting on Wednesday that is quite
important for many of the worshipers and
we see the numbers of the people
visiting the Muslim people who are
visiting the compound is increasing so
that decision is also another sign of
de-escalation however that we cannot say
that there is a unity in the Israeli
cabinet or the among the Israeli
officials so the national security
minister
has said that he is opposing this
decision and he said that as Wednesday
is going to be the EU of the Jewish
Passover Jeeves the nationalists should
be allowed at least once to be getting
into the compound and if that happens
definitely there will be another
escalation because uh because we're
afraid that the Israeli occupation
forces will try once again to forcefully
remove the Palestinian worshipers okay
thank you so much we'll definitely be
keeping an eye on developments there
that's racist for us and occupied
Jerusalem